oh
bonsoir des bonnes à l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs ce soir
avec deux invités avec donc et loire aux
langes d'abord bonsoir stephen alors je
vous rappelle que je ne suis pas seul à
profiter puisque je suis commerçante
auteurs de cette émission et nous avons
effectivement invité d'honneur ce soir
puisqu'il s'agit de lionel gold évite
chaleur bonsoir lionel le pont soirée
loi bonsoir stéphane merci de me
recevoir pour cette émission alors
invité spécial ce soir parce qu'on va
parler abondamment évidemment va revenir
sur ton à sarajevo tout à l'heure en
commentant la partie adams contre morrow
zellik et on va parler surtout du toit
de leone qui viennent de démarrer en
espagne tournoi de 27 ch est-ce
peut-être qu'il peut nous en parler un
peu plus cette spécialiste des
ordinateurs et s'il s'agit de tournois
où les ordinateurs ont une part
non-négligeable absolument effectivement
actuellement les joueurs du tournoi vont
utiliser des ordinateurs pour donc un
petit peu élevé la qualité du jeu en
tout cas c'est peut-être le prétexte se
croient qu'ils qui a été un petit peu
été mis en place pour organiser ce type
de compétition tout cas sans eau
courante est en discuter plus plus tard
oui mais bon même tout de suite mais je
crois que c'est tout simplement ça a été
inaugurée par kasparov ya à peu près
deux ans je crois dans son premier match
contre topaloff et moi j'ai le sentiment
je sais pas si vous partagez un petit
peu mon avis
que finalement ça a été un moyen pour
kasparov de de faire en sorte que les
échecs sont un petit peu plus populaires
en amenant des grandes compagnies
pourquoi pas dans les tournois et c'est
le cas puisque aujourd'hui en faisant
des partis avec des ordinateurs d'échec
on a la possibilité d'avoir des
partenaires comme des grandes maisons
informatique on peut penser maintenant
ma compagne ça pue ça peut penser un
petit pourront ça me fait penser un
petit peu aller à des petites rallye
automobile ou kasparov a ouvert un peu
la porte à beaucoup de partenariats
possibles alors dans le jeu qu'est ce
que ça donne comment ça se passe
concrètement alors concrètement les
joueurs ont à leur disposition un
ordinateur sur lequel ils ont à ma
connaissance plusieurs logiciels
d'installer des logiciels de base de
données que je pense tout le monde
connaît aujourd'hui qui apporte une aide
considérable au cours d'une partie
puisqu'on peut à n'importe quel moment
avoir à sa disposition un petit peu de
tout l'historique des échecs toutes les
parties ont été jouées au préalable
éventuellement les analyses que les
joueurs peuvent avoir à leur disposition
ils ont aussi des logiciels de jeux qui
peuvent utiliser et c'est pas
négligeable surtout dans les positions
extrêmement tactique puisque on sait
qu'aujourd'hui les ordinateurs son
redoutable dans cette phase de jeu
alors elle est loi qu'est ce que qu'est
ce que ça donne au niveau des partis
donc c'est avec les
logiciel c'est plus parties sont plus
d'aucune de meilleur niveau ou qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire oui
alors on peut dire qu'effectivement les
parties sont d'un niveau médiocre
probablement au niveau de la qualité de
jeu mais surtout ce qui fait la
différence c'est que il ya plus de bluff
il n'y a vraiment plus de blocs possible
c'est à dire que une fois que la partie
est lancée
une fois que les complications sont
commencés et bien on sait que les
joueurs ne vont plus faire d'erreurs et
ça c'est moins effectivement ça enlève
un peu de piment mais on augmente la
qualité de l'eau alors c'est toujours
cette fameuse dualité entre enfin le
débat est-ce qu'il faut mettre
est ce qu'il faut faire jouer les
ordinateurs avec les humains c'est dire
que ya moins de fautes
mais d'un autre côté est ce que c'est
pas les fautes qui font le piment du jeu
d'échecs donc je pense que le gros débat
il tout simplement
alors justement qu'est ce que tu en
penses bayonnais donc moi je vous
avouerai que c'est la question que je me
suis un petit peu longtemps posée
pourquoi finalement apporter ce plus qui
peut ne pas en être ça c'est un avis
personnel score enlever la fente du
joueur
mais ça ce qui se passe absolument ce
qui caractérise une partie d'échecs est
ce que je trouve beau dans une partie
d'échecs c'est cette confrontation cet
échange d'idées qui fait que l'homme est
humain finalement et s'il fait une faute
c'est partie intégrante du jeu
alors le fait d'avoir des ordinateurs à
sa disposition permet entre guillemets
d'augmenter la qualité du jeu mais est
ce qu'est ce qu'on en a réellement
besoin est ce que c'est un réel intérêt
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait cette petite
parenthèse en début d'émission ou pour
ma part ça a été un moyen pour kasparov
qui est un homme d'affaires aussi
talentueux le talentueux peut-être que
joueur d'échecs de dames d'amener ou
peut-être moi d'amener en tout cas des
partenaires et banias et à s'affairer la
loi et l'aurait pas d'accord c'est à
dire que kasparov aux échecs est quand
même extrêmement fort en business il a
encore tout à prouver
c'est kasparov aux échecs et quand même
reconnu mondialement et edf on va pas
non plus qu paris castorf champion du
monde d'échecs les casteurs of business
man en tout cas moi j'ai le sentiment
vous soulignez que le tout ça a démarré
à partir d'une idée de croix de kasparov
et est ce que tout ça finalement n'est
pas une possibilité marketing pour les
échecs d'avoir des partenaires éventuels
plutôt cruellement d'augmenter la
qualité du jeu parce que je suis pas
persuadé que bon la qualité du jeu
augment probablement c'est vrai mais
lorsqu'on a besoin d'avoir ces photos
étaient quand même que c'est une heure
car ou un seigneur que c'est une heure
pour toute la partie au carreau c'est à
dire que si on est passionnant de
réflexion on a perdu
donc ça laisse à 1h40 c'est quand même
pas non plus les partie de 2h40 coup
suivi d'une heure
que trois heures 6 heures de jeu
possible là c'est deux heures de jeu
maximum donc ça ça peut limiter aussi la
qualité du jeu parce qu'on part en dit
que les ordinateurs par porter même plus
mais comme la réflexion illimité
d'assassinât - telle qualité tout à fait
on a moins le temps de les utiliser
donc finalement ça ça reviendrait à dire
qu'elle est qu'elle est finalement un
avantage d'avoir ces ordinateurs alors à
sa disposition en cours de partie puis
sourit non mais il faut pas non plus de
mélanger la qualité de jeu on blitz et
la qualité de l'eau en partie classique
c'est dire que le temps n'a rien à voir
et tout ça si de toute façon contre
oeuvres ajoute un ordinateur un joueur
il jouera le la symbiose aussi la
symbiose a bien fait on aura une
meilleure qualité de l'eau douce est
évident maintenant là on peut je veux
dire on peut toujours dire que dans une
heure avec l'ordinateur on va moins bien
joué quand deux heures sans ordinateur
mais c'est un débat qui n'a pas de sens
ça n'a pas de sens tout simplement mais
par contre je voudrais revenir sur ce
cri parce qu'elles viennent à la 10e
place au niveau du marketing & noack et
c'est vrai que kader arif
bon enfin les ordinateurs ont été
intégrés dans les temps - et ça
effectivement ça amène de l'argent c'est
la fameuse polémique du championnat de
hollande le championnat national des
pays-bas ou simplement les ordinateurs
se sont fait acheter entre guillemets
puisque c'est pas exactement ces termes
là qu'il faudrait présenter et se sont
fait acheter par une compagnie c'est
vers le logiciel freaks la firme
allemande de chasse base qui a
simplement payer pour que son programme
joue ce fameux championnat national donc
là il ya un autre débat effectivement
est ce que l'argent venu de ces grosses
sociétés informatiques et bienvenue ou
en tout cas est-ce qu'il est bienvenue à
cet endroit là précisément serré au
championnat de hollande ou championnat
national d'un pays
donc là il ya une autre question à
creuser mais ce n'est pas l'ordinateur
qui a gagné a fait alors c'est n'est pas
l'ordinateur qui aligne effectivement
mais c'est un tournoi deux parties
longues là le temps intervient puisqu'on
ses complices l'ordinateur est vraiment
très fort alors que dans ce championnat
c'était du 2h40 kourou et 1h cas où
l'autre pas donc si l'heure de jeu et là
effectivement la créativité humaine a
encore le temps de s'exprimer
on n'est pas sur un jeu basé uniquement
sur le calcul net des variantes et on
peut d'ailleurs l'ordinateur a subi des
défaites absolument époustouflant
notamment dans sa partie contre van de
weghe ouais c'est très mal parti de ben
ali qui a écrasé la machine
alors on a peut-être parler comme des
participants à ce tournoi de vente de
lait sommes donc chacun donc joue avec
un ordinateur
donc on a eu droit aujourd'hui à la
première ronde de ce tournoi il ya
quatre joueurs en tout il ya shirov un
précédent vainqueur du grand prix du
sénat donc quand on retrouve et qui a
fait un super tournoi sarajevo ce qui
les terminent deuxièmes ex-aequo
donc je vis des ragas parents fléchir
fort ce moment c'est l'homme en forme on
le redira jamais assez il a gagné le
du sénat ensuite il a gagné enfin il
accueille quasiment gagné sarivo
puisqu'ils terminent deuxièmes derrière
kasparov mais en ayant dominé tout le
tournoi et là donc ils jouent contre
l'idée ce casque m'a fort grands maîtres
à 2650 second dans le panneau hier
chronique et il commence par lui coller
de zéro ce qui est quand même une belle
performance on est 2 0 et un esclave qui
est le champion d'espagne de leicester
champion d'espagne 1999 et dans la
deuxième moitié de tableau on retrouve à
nantes donc numéro tout court numéro 2
mondial et judit polgar voilà qu'on
retrouve ici j'ai dit aux gars café on
en parlera dans les news qui a fait un
excellent tournoi en suède
oui alors ça c'est effectivement c'est
également une belle affiche ses sorties
4,4 très fort joueur dans ce tournoi il
est ce cas c'est donc le côté espagnol
ah non déchire offs et les meilleurs
mondiaux et judit polgar qu'est la
meilleure féminine
bon je pense que l'idée est de voir si
l'ordinateur va être bien utilisé et qui
va au mieux utiliser l'ordinateur
puisque vraisemblablement au final on
aura schirrhoffen ondes
bon si la loi du vélo est respecté et là
on va voir lequel travaille le plus avec
l'ordinateur on va voir aussi au niveau
de la qualité des parties 6 anne va bien
l'utiliser parce que par exemple on se
rappelle de karpov qu'elle joue contre
topalov je crois il n'avait pas réussi à
utiliser du tout voilà deux ans c'était
pas top c'est un jeu contre ajoie très
peu moins d'un an que je crois contraint
d'en louer et là effectivement il
n'était pas sorti il était emmené
menottes s'est-elle absolument
insupportable et donc tirent prof avait
pas du tout mais alors pas du tout su
gérer l'ordinateur qui n'est
effectivement pas de son époque
oui il est pas tellement un jeu pas
tellement branchée à un ordinateur parce
qu'il a quand même appris à s'en servir
et ses résultats à mon avis le prouve
mais c'est vrai que c'est un point
important puisque aujourd'hui on a plus
en plus de logiciels qui arrive c'est un
petit peu sur le marché et ses leçons
des logiciels qui demande une phase de
formation qui peut prendre du temps
et effectivement pour pouvoir les
utiliser à 100% leurs capacités il faut
il faut du temps à consacrer à
l'utilisation de ses logiciels et ce
sont des joueurs qui n'ont pas forcément
le temps m'a d'un petit peu de de
persévérer son fonctionnement de
certains logiciels willaya autre chose à
dire effectivement sur les échecs et
l'informatique c'est que maintenant la
jeune génération joue clairement mieux
c'est à dire qu'ils sont tout de suite
et sont dans le bain l'informatique
ils ont un ordinateur au berceau
pratiquement c'est à dire que je ne sais
pas à quel âge on commence à en douter à
partir de 6 ans ont sept ans déjà ils
peuvent commencer à tapoter sur le
clavier ça donne une seule
nature chez les nouveaux joueurs
d'échecs donc par exemple on peut dire
que ponomariov bacrot tous les jeunes
actuels problèmes l'embout mondeville
qui est encore plus jeunes ont tous
bénéficié d'un ordinateur très jeune et
là on voit les performances de ces
petits ont 13 ans 14 ans 15 ans qui sont
de plus en plus forte et de plus en plus
remarquable en tout cas pour des jeunes
de cet âge là donc ça a probablement
fait augmenter la vitesse de progression
des jeunes d'accord donc alors un acte
une excuse mais on peut peut-être aussi
souligné la forte progression actuelle
des logiciels et de leurs performances
au niveau mais pour l'instant on n'a pas
trouvé de logiciels encore qui
permettent de battre enfin de gagner à
tous les coups ça n'existe pas encore
non je pense que des études
mathématiques montre que d'ici 25 ans à
l'ordinateur sera capable de calculer
toutes les conséquences d'une partie
d'échecs
c'est à dire qu'il aura la capacité de
calcul d'à peu près 30 cerveau humain et
il sera donc capable de déterminer si le
khat est un gros coup je l'espère en
tout cas parce que j'ai toujours cru
dans ce coup et j'ai joué pendant de
nombreuses années mais il affichera
effectivement eu quatre bons coups et
qu'un an 87 coups comme ça existe
aujourd'hui pour certains connaisseurs
peut-être qu'ils connaissent le logiciel
pour les finales vous avez un logiciel
qui permet d'avoir une analyse
exhaustive sur toutes les finales de
moins de cinq pièces alors c'est
effectivement très impressionnant vous
mettez une position de 25 pièces sur
l'échiquier est automatiquement
l'ordinateur vous dresse la liste de
tous les coups possibles dans la
position
et puis vous dit pareil qu'avec 4 va
mener un gain forcé en 81 coups font
descendre bien fermé dans un an au final
de moins de cinq pièces sont bouclés
déjà elles sont déjà bouclés ça a été
fait par un programmeur talentueux qui
s'appelle ken thompson qui aussi
programmeurs pour les informaticiens du
système d'exploitation unix et
effectivement ça nous déjà ça nous
montre un petit peu ce qu'on aura
peut-être la chance de connaître à la
chance ou la malchance je ne sais pas de
connaître d'ici d'ici quelques années en
tout cas non oui alors pourquoi un peu
lionel a été champion d'europe cadets en
semi rapide et qu'il est donc maintenant
développeur informatique donc j'ai une
question que j'ai envie de lui poser
c'est est-ce que ton avis pour résoudre
le jeu d'échec on va partir de la
position de départ où partir de là de la
fin
moi j'ai le sentiment qu'avec la
puissance des calculs des ordinateurs
tout simplement l'ordinateur qu'elle
fera toutes les possibilités à partir du
départ parce que ça sent plus simple à
à mettre en place et donc sera capable
de déterminer
finalement quelle est la meilleure
stratégie à partir du moment où il y
aura calculé tout simplement toutes les
possibilités comme c'est le cas avec
d'autres jeux où on sait que des
morpions très simples sont limitées
puisque l'ordinateur a calculé déjà
toutes les possibilités et de parcelles
je ne sais pas si vous connaissez le jeu
de go la l'ordinateur est extrêmement
faible à ce jeu alors d'avoir une
explication est moins développée en fait
c'est simplement par rapport aux
possibilités mathématiques encore une
fois le goût à beaucoup plus de
possibilités que les échecs c'est ce qui
fait qu'actuellement il est moins
d'efforts aussi fait dans le gouf aussi
un horizon de quatre heures au moins
deux joueurs de go que deux joueurs
d'échecs déjà donc oui c'est l'intérieur
de loin dont il ya des mégots représente
un intérêt au niveau de la programmation
pour les concept d'intelligence
artificielle ça a toujours été une
difficulté et c'est vrai que le
problématique actuellement du beau c'est
que le nom de possibilité mathématique
est bien supérieur aux échecs c'est ce
qui fait que qu'actuellement on n'a pas
du tout d'équivalent en gros au niveau
des programmes et leur force de jeu par
rapport aux échecs mais effectivement
c'est comme aux échecs deep blue quand
même battu kasparov au bon on en est
très loin donc enfin ça c'est une
parenthèse la mettre sur le dos par
exemple un autre jeu puisqu'on
du multi jeu ce soir dès leur exercice
la plus connue sous le nom d'hôtel au
qui lui a été complètement résolu depuis
le début donc ce jeune homme ne présente
plus a un intérêt majeur ne serait ce
que pour les pratiquants et qui n'ont
qu'à se référer à la partie idéale joué
par ordinateur donc là ya pas deux mais
en tout cas aux échecs on en est pas
encore là donc 25 ans d'une prévision
donc on a encore 25 ans pour pour
s'amuser mais il sera peut-être déjà
trop tard avancez vous avec les
seychelles avec ses albums
je crois que ce sera jamais trop tard on
va parler d'eux
aussi de tes réalisations nouvelles donc
tu travailles sur le palm pilot et tu as
fait un programme qui s'appelle qui
s'appelle punchs s alors le palm pilot
c'est un petit ordinateur de poche et
donc j'ai réalisé un programme de base
de données il fonctionne sur cet
ordinateur
c'est un programme pour un appareil pour
ceux qui connaissent cas c'est
impressionnant parce que c'est une
épaisseur quasiment de la taille d'un
petit portefeuille
ça peut se glisser dans une poche de
chemise et j'ai réalisé un programme sur
lequel vous avez des milliers de parties
un petit chef base finalement sur un
ordinateur de poche qui fait
qu'actuellement
mais aujourd'hui n'importe qui peut
avoir sur soi des milliers de parties
des petites combinaisons qu'il acquit la
résoudre il décide on peut télécharger
je pense pas me laisse à le logiciel est
en téléchargement sur le site panache
s.com et pour actuellement je suis très
très content du succès qu'il a à travers
un petit peu le monde puisqu'il ya 7000
personnes qui ont déjà utilisé mon
logiciel voilà bon bah on a fait ce
petit ourson les ordinateurs je crois
qu'on a un peu tout balayé il ya
peut-être un peu rapidement les
résultats de cette pièce qui a commencé
en gironde espèces de 0 et 1 1 en
première soit nous demain à montpellier
ce jour demain donc évidemment compte
rendu la semaine prochaine pour ce
tournoi s'adresse
on va voir tout de suite maintenant la
partie de la semaine si on peut envoyer
là invaincu
voilà donc tout de suite donc la partie
de la semaine avec la partie entre
michael adams est bon aux élites show
tournoi de sarajevo où une très jolie
partie de l'inde à la dernière ronde
oui et l'autre de sarajevo effectivement
rappelez vous c'était y'a pas si
longtemps il ya eu tous les flashs
spéciaux de diagonale donc si vous
voulez un rendez compte rendu complet
sur le tournoi je vous invite à aller
dans les déférer de diagonale pour tout
revoir
en tout cas là on va s'intéresser à
cette partie adams morose et beach qui
n'a pas été commentée du relais flash ce
qui avait deux autres très belles
parties qui ont été jouées simultanément
mais celle là vaut également son pesant
d'or donc adams contre morrow des beach
le numéro 7 contre le numéro 5 mondial
adam szalai blanc et ouvre avec le coup
1 e4
donc si on je pense qu'on va bientôt
passer en incrustation en bas à droite
de l'échiquier michael adams
effectueront jeu toujours le groupe de
quatre où il est mort on évite lui à sa
défense fétiche qui est donc la défense
française et il joue ici e6 e7 e6 qui
caractérise la défense française alors
lionel je crois que tu un spécialiste de
sa défense française puisque tu as un
joueur réputé pour avoir le même
répertoire depuis depuis que tu joues de
deux piliers un peu donc la défense
française absolument disons que je suis
quelqu'un qui a des habitudes et qui
aime bien les garder surtout lorsqu'elle
me donne des résultats mais je sais par
ailleurs que c'est mon principal défaut
quand je n'en dirai pas plus sur mes
défauts on va continuer à regarder de la
partie c'est un avantage est un des
fonds ouais donc des quatre des cinq
cavaliers d2 donc là c'est la variante
tard h si je dis pas de seulement si je
dis pas d'erreur c'est bien davantage le
pion aux quatre étaient attaqués on le
défend avec lecavalier
c'est un des moyens de défendre cette
position fawcett alors là c'est le
dernier cri de la technologie puisque
c'est là ça va contre les principes de
l'ouverture qui sont quand même sortez
vos cavaliers avant les fous donc ici il
faut êtes alors je ne sais pas peut-être
qu'il y en avait beaucoup
moi ça fait très longtemps que j'ai raté
de la défense française et ce faux 7 me
paraît toujours aussi surprenant qu'au
premier jour alors c'est un à mon avis
ça donne un petit coup d'attentes où
finalement les noirs attendre de voir
comment les blancs vont un petit peu se
développer puisqu'il finit finalement
ils n'ont rien promis pour l'instant ils
se réservent la possibilité de jouer
c'est simple de façon agressive sur 1,5
éventuelles
il attendait un petit peu de voir
comment les pièces blanches vont se
développer dans cette position qui reste
quand même relativement fragile par
rapport aux la mise en place des
dépositions des pièces donc fawcett est
un conte souple on attend de voir ce que
font les blancs foot est roi
donc les blancs eux aussi je ressemble
tout simple logique l'a noté qu' on a
l'impression que les noirs peuvent
prendre le pion 20,4 et ensuite prendre
le pian 2 des 4 oui alors effectivement
ça amènerait à une pointe
on va regarder ça donc tu reprends pions
le 4 est une possibilité
le cavalier viendrait reprendre ici et
maintenant on peut se dire effectivement
le pire des cas très en place par la
dame je vais le prendre
donc d'un cran dès 4 mais ça serait
tombé dans un piège grossier d'ouverture
c'était un peu là le fou viendrait sur
la case b5 échec en échec au roi
il faut parer l'échec et la dame est
perdue puisque les huit reprises par la
dame blanche
voilà les questions et des réponses donc
c'est ça exactement ça donc ici on ne
peut pas aller chercher sur des 4 on
joue donc le coup c'est cette c5 qui est
un levier classique dans la française on
ne leur en as l'impression sans
secousses et 5
quand utiliser le coup fawcett était
curieux puisque ce fou contrôler la
casse et saint cloud testing maintenant
si des blancs prennent de ces sexes a
obligé de reprendre du fou et bien
d'ailleurs c'est la partie c'est la
plante son plein dans ses 5
effectivement pour exploiter cette
éventuelle perte de temps côté noir
c'est à dire que si le four prend
maintenant on se retrouve avec plus ou
moins une position qui pourrait être
théorique mais il y aura un temps de
mots donc tout simplement ça serait une
mauvaise opération pour les noirs et
donc on va vite je continue dans son
idée joue cavalier un f6 celle qui veut
pas reprendre se tourne tout de suite ou
en tout cas il veut d'abord essayé
d'éclairer un peu la situation au centre
donc là bien entendu l'idée c'est de
tout premiers quatre échanges et les
dames ensuite récupéré pioncer 5 avec
une position qui se rapproche de
l'égalité michael adams joda me2 donc là
on s'aperçoit tout de suite que l'option
c'est ça qui est assez dur à aller
chercher puisque ça s'exposera enfin de
la riante un échec en d5 a lancé c'est
vrai que c'est un peu une vente complexe
à voir mais sur trois 1,4 cavalli prend
1,4 si on échange encore le fou par
pondre et surtout prend ses seins qui
aura cet échec d'amd 5 donc la suivante
un peu un peu fumeuse mais en tout cas
de toute façon aux ouvertures et une
règle très simple il ne faut pas trop se
presser de chercher des ventes compliqué
et tactique
il faut avant tout bien placé ses forces
et donc ça s'appelle le développement
des pièces tout simplement dans le noir
on pas récupéré un pion c5 les noirs en
tâtonnements milon sorties 38 mineurs ce
qui est pas mal dans la mesure où on
peut considérer que le canadien en d2d
blanc il n'est pas sorti puisqu'il
empêche le phocéen de se développer donc
là au niveau du temps les noirs sont en
avance par contre au niveau du matériel
c'est les blanquillos un peu plus
toujours cette dualité tactique ni le
statique et dynamique
voilà qu'elle est gf3 cavell et b4 donc
là les noirs commencent à jouer pour le
jeu statique c'est à dire qu'ils veulent
prendre la paire de fous moi il me parle
me fous des 3l 100 comme se retrouver
mêlé de fou voilà ces retrouvailles de
fou contre justement contre fou et
cavaliers et ça c'est un avantage
certain puisque ça nous permet d'avoir
justement contrôle sur toutes les cases
de loin puisque le fou travail de loin
mais uniquement sur une couleur lequel
il travaille de près et sur toutes les
couleurs donc de pousser très fort
effectivement c'est la peur de fous
qu'elle valait b3 michael adams mis
d'accord pour mon fou
par contre moi je vais garder mon pions
peut-être insisté sur un point qui est
très important pour les joueurs qui
signe ici un petit peu aux échecs c'est
qu'en principe il est
il faut pas déplu à vous développer
enfin je bougeais deux fois la même
pièce en cours de jeu mais les noirs
viennent de le faire avec validé quatre
îles et blanc le font avec un lit bitran
alors je suis juste aux coups précédents
on peut aussi s'interroger effectivement
sur les placements du cavalier mais en
règle générale il faut éviter de
développer le cavalier plusieurs fois de
suite spécialement lorsqu'on a un pion
de moins et effectivement comme nous
elle souligne l idée d des noirs et et
d'obtenir des avantages statique c'est à
dire de prendre des avantages au niveau
de la paire de fou comme tu le soulignes
est et d'ensuite misé sur la
récupération du pion c5 avec avantage
voilà tout à fait donc l'option ses
singles est trop long un peu difficile à
défendre et clément puisqu'il est déjà
très avancé non c'est ce qu'on va voir
donc déjà très logiquement les noirs
prennent la paire de fou qu'est les
premiers 3 on reprend du pied ce qui
nous permettra de jouer donc des trois
des quatre cibles un drap ce pion c5
parce que ça sera défendue en diagonale
le cou à cette a5 et la michael adams
innove puisque dans sa dernière partie
contre morrow ceviches av c'est
exactement cette position-là et michael
adams
c'était prémunit contre se coupe à cinq
ans jouant à 2 à 4 donc ou logique c'est
la réaction logique qu'on a toujours
envie de jouer aux échecs quand il ya un
coût qui est jouée comme h5 ou à 5 on a
envie de jouer à 4 ou h4 effectivement
c'est la réaction normale benaid joue un
coup un peu nouveau le couffo g5
donc c'est la deuxième fois que ça a été
joué ça déjà été joué une fois par
topaloff né me semble faux g5 qui ne
donc qui permet aux noirs de jouer le
coup à 4 qu'ils font ici pour chasser le
cavalier en même temps guérit l'espace
le cavalier de michael adams revient sur
la thèse des deux médecins il faut
sortie et non pas sur attaque voilà
c'est exactement ça a tout changé ils
assortissent enfants il revient avec son
cavalier et ne revient pas sur la case
des caps puisqu'il veut garder cette
option de mettre l'option détroit en d4
toujours pour soutenir pour former une
chaîne de pions qui se tiennent et là
par exemple les noirs pourrait
difficilement prendre ces cinq
probablement à cause du coût 4 5 puisque
le canal de sicile cloud lesquels m6
serait donc perdu tout simplement
puisque serait cloué y aurait peut-être
acheté skype solution pour sauver
éventuellement le cavalier mais après
puis on prend cavaliers puis on prend g5
lui plongé c'est très stressant brise
oui alors ça c'est effectivement là on
arrive à les vendre plus compliqué il ya
aussi fois jusqu'à objets cinq cas les
projets sens comme dans le gambit
dominique mais effectivement là ses
variantes pour experts donc on va pas
les détailler ici puisque ce n'est pas
le but cette émission donc ici on ne
joue pas on va se contenter de dire ça
on ne reprend pas le pur c5 puisqu'après
le coup le 4 e 5
il y aurait donc un clouage puisque le
fonds ne seraient plus sur l'a47
on peut aussi globalement indiqué que
les toutes les pièces blanches sont
développées alors quelle caisse noire
l'instant sont loin d'être sorties
notamment avec le fameux problème de la
défense française qu'ils font ces huit
noms qui restent encore en murray à
travers ses propres pions et on peut
avec un petit peu d'intuition quand même
évalué que finalement à près de 5 le
l'ouverture des lignes risquer de
profiter un plus au blanco noir dans la
mesure où leurs pièces sont déjà en
action
wayne effectivement h 10 et là on donne
le deuxième souffle point m6 alors ça
c'est très bien joué puisque avec cet
échange donc vous évite je reprends du
fou et maintenant il ya un enchaînement
de michael adams c'est qu'ils jouent le
haut 4,5 et il va fermer la position
c'est dire que là il ya une règle
générale à connaître contre la paire de
fou il vaut mieux fermer la transition
oui enfin voire même contre un fou de
toute façon contraints foule il y avait
donc si on a deux effectivement aux
fermes encore plus la position et c'est
là ce qui va être fait fawcett
donc on ne joue pas le coût des trois
des quatre trop vite puisque sur des
trois décades donc on va le mentionner
puisque c'est très important ici
l'option c5 est attaqué par le fawcett
et on pourrait défendre avec notre pions
là effectivement on est tenté de se dire
ça oui mais là il y aurait 17 b6 est
tout de suite des pointes commencent à
surgir sur cette diagonale
vous pouvez maintenant se développer aux
menaces de prendre l'avion c'est 5
donc ça devient difficile et là ça
devient assez compliqué donc ici il ne
faut pas se presser de jouer les coups
donc d3 d4 michael adams midi tranquille
très flegmatique
fidèle à son style joue tour c'est un
défaut un pion et donc garde en même
temps le contrôle des cases blanches
donc là michael adams garde les cases
blanches et des terres rares
donc ils gardent de tout en fait tout
simplement morose et beach essaie de le
pousser à la faute
je torah 5 et un résident ou d3 d4 dit
justin theroux et michael adams nom joue
d'amoureux 3 et en plus ils enlèvent la
dame de ce2 de cette possibilité pour
les normes je me fonds à six en cas d'un
v6 oui oui donc l'arrivée notamment de
trois défend l'option c5 donc la
location c'est ça qui a défendu deux
fois il a attaqué deux fois donc c'est
bon il tient ça c'est une première
remarque alors ici vendée beach arrête
data question et joue petit roth
il aurait pu jouer dans ces sept qu'on
va regarder maintenant dame ses sets
c'est une autre possibilité la ces
attaques encore le pion et si on arrive
à provoquer à jouer donc ce coup des
trois des quatre fers n'aurais je pas
manquer puisque la tomme service oracle
aurait donc nécessaire et ici tout
simplement petit rock on n'a pas besoin
d'un défendre l'option c'est ça qui est
bien
alors s'il faut campion déjà très
simplement on joue des trois des quatre
ayant le fonds qui sera cloué n en
fonction de troubler la question cette
option
voilà évidemment et ici il y à tour pro
tour et comprend tout enfin non c'est
pas clair alors si c'est ici c'est très
clair ça gagne de manière forcément deux
possibilités soit d'en prendre soin fou
qu'on va regarder le fond qu'est la plus
compliquée puisque la france était très
simple bonjour tour c'est un donc
attaque le fou
si on défend fou avec le pion b là il ya
des trois des quatre qui est le faux
mais si on prend la dame donc fou
programme pour kung fu on s'en fout il
ya deux menaces tout prend ses 8
et puis on prend un full 3 qui gagne
tout pensé une gagne la tourache 8
donc ça oblige et noir odébit contre
attaque sur la tour
mais la grande deux possibilités de
gagner pour penser vite qui va prendre
de fou pour une tour mon tour contre 9 7
avec une finale gagnante donc deux
possibilités pour gagner juste une
petite remarque très rapidement dans
cette position là on peut aussi je veux
dame française
mais ça ne change pas grand-chose à la
faire puisqu'il ya toujours ce fou s'est
vite car aux prises derrière enfin deux
variantes ici il y aurait d'un programme
fou prend dames et c'est là et on voit
que les fous sont gênés puisque pour
l'heure d'attaquer la seconde
donc là on va ramasser un fou donc ici
très très simple il a déjà gagné la
bataille michael adams puisqu'il on ne
peut plus arrêter de penser ça donc on
ne peut pas je vous aime c'est cette ça
ne sert à rien donc on joue petit rock
michael adams rock aussi et maintenant
ça y est c'est tranquille puisque toi
qui l'as rockets il peut jouer d3 d4
donc conservés sont en plus donc ici
déjà michael adams appris appris en fait
la plus grosse et après on a pris
l'ascendant
il a pris un gros avantage est jamais
plaint on peut dire que ça fout 17 là le
fameux fou de la française que lunel
connaîtra bien que tous les genres de
françaises connaissent c'est le fou qui
ne ressort jamais quand il ressort il
est extrêmement fort alors qu'en
principe lorsqu'il ressort c'est lé soin
que la position est bonne pour les noirs
soit qu'on a besoin de moins c'est
effectivement qu'elle s'y est donc il
sait qu'il a plus vraiment plus le choix
lorsque vous jouez fou 17 c'est c'est
dans ce type de position que déjà ça
reste difficile donc la dia purement
effectivement michael adams masse ces
pièces sur le pion c'est sans doute
ahidjo tour ces deux donc l'idée de ce
qu'on est
évidemment nous d'oublier tout d'un
hello tour pour avoir deux tours sur la
colonne s'est alors pourquoi cette
colonne ci a été importante et bien
évidemment parce qu'elle est amenée à ce
moyen puisque les noirs ne peuvent pas
tolérer espérances et 5 vont donc
forcément joué 17 des six est là il y
aura échange de pions donc la colonne
c'est sera la seule colonne ouverte donc
très importante donc ici évidemment un
petit coup de prophylaxie une manoeuvre
prophylactique de michael adams
mais ça ça ne nous surprend pas puisque
c'est comme un joueur très fort en qui
connaît donc la prophylaxie dame habite
toi c'est un très logique donc ces huit
donc dame a vu ses dépôts ramené à tout
moment oui et ça c'est de payer
effectivement lors ça je suis passé
rapidement sur ce détail il a en fait il
a libéré de la place pour la tournée
c'est exactement ça et maintenant
michael adams le faire
montrez un plan très puissant puisqu'il
va se servir du pion c5 son cours le
plus pour faire une diversion alors j'en
profite au passage pour vous signaler
que si vous allez sur le tchat
il y à jean-luc chavanon qui vous attend
en direct vous pouvez donc lui poser vos
questions et si vous avez des questions
techniques effectivement si vous ne
comprenez pas ce qu'on dit vous pouvez
toujours lui demander il est là en
direct et il attend vos propos et
remarque donc dit oui alors je donc je
reviens sur cette explication si on va
un parti qui est critique
sire que michael allan soit faire toute
une diversion il va dire voilà le pion
c5
je vais à long terme le rendre mais en
revanche cet or a pris tellement de
temps que tu auras complètement négligé
la protection de ton roi donc la fête je
cible adams parlant morozevich tu auras
complètement négligé la protection 3 et
je vais donc tassées des coups mortels
de ce côté là donc du côté droite de
l'échiquier et c'est exactement ce qui
va se passer
ça commence par 19 cas là des f1 pour
l'instant l'option n'est pas en prison
moreau ceviche l'attaqué avec damas est
donc un taquet pions et laon le fameux
conte des trois des quatre mois il a
cité un peu tard pour faire cesser un
peu tôt 10 ans pour des élections dont
je veux d'abord des spas des cartes
donc on a réussi à consolider le tout en
plus on a consolidé le toit plus alors
sur bessette b6 pour l'instant ce n'est
pas possible puisque aurait simplement
que tu reprends pion qui attaqueraient
la dame donc maintenant les noirs vont
tout mettre en oeuvre pour jouer ce
coupé cette v6 damas six cavaliers g3 on
continue à aller à l'attack des six les
noirs ne peuvent plus tenir dans cette
position ils sont complètement dominé il
faut ouvrir le jeu donc sur surprend bay
city aurait il commencera à y avoir du
contre je après tourcoing tours et d'un
pro b 6 et des colonnes ouvert que les
fous qui pourrait commencer à sortir
michael adams préfère continuer la
diversion et joue ses six attaquants
fouille des sacs en fou fou invite donc
la michael adams sait pertinemment que
son fiancé 6 ne pourra pas tenir il est
trop coupé du reste de ses pièces qui
sont toutes là mais c'est pas grave
puisque justement comme ces pièces sont
toutes du côté droit légitime va donner
le pion aux hivers essaie de tenir ses
pions le plus longtemps possible pour
passer de l'autre côté et donc gagner la
partie
c'est ce qu'on va voir tout de suite car
à 10 h 5 il commence à y aller morose
évident gendarmes en b 5
attac renoncer si ce donc là ça y est
morose et du vice champion et l'a donc
posez vous la question comment attaquer
de la façon la plus efficace pour les
blancs c'est un sachant que sur ces six
va tomber et que si on laisse trop
trouve au noir et m'a finalement les
noirs vont réussir leur opération et
obtenir du contre jeu côté gauche
donc il faut être très efficace alors il
ya effectivement dans ce type de
position des petites questions clés
qu'on peut se poser et qui peuvent
amener justement à trouver le coup alors
que l'une des questions les plus simples
c'est qu'elle l'ait finalement la pièce
la plus mal placée dans ma position
ici on s'aperçoit puis les tours
blanches vont être difficiles à
améliorer que la dame blanche est
idéalement placé le cavalier h5 est
magique
il reste plus qu'un seul détail et loi
alors via ce moyen lequel edf 3 qui est
pas spécialement de replacer et donc il
va falloir l'améliorer
effectivement et là comment faire pour
l'améliorer on voit effectivement le cas
oliech trois là il peut pas aller là non
plus là non plus hélas non plus alors
tout ça parce que justement le fou
contrôle il faut donc mettre en place un
process qui va améliorer la pression
amicale et f3 française et alors là le
process justement c'est ce coup j'ai 2,4
alors là c'est la guerre est déclarée la
guerre est ouverte puisque ce coup j'ai
cas n'est pas naturel on ne joue jamais
sauf quand c'est pour le dé lancer une
attaque c'est par goût défensif qu'il
faut pas du tout l'interpréter autrement
on veut pas faire une casse de fuite
pour le roi là on veut vraiment prendre
ce pion et d'envoyer comme un bellier
vers le roi noir donc là le but c'est de
jouer g4 g5 pour casser un peu la leur
en parant du rendement à anvers et
surtout comme l'a dit lionel mettre ce
cavalier l' enjeu puisque après g5 la
prise va être forcé on va reprendre du
cavalier et on aura donc deux cavaliers
imaginez les biens vous les redécouvrir
angers 5 et h5 qui sont vraiment
extrêmement fort et donc il explose
complètement la position du roi noir
défense de michael adams demandez vite
de boer revitch tout à fait savoir lundi
qu'elle aidera ils jouent tour à sept
alors a mentionné comme dans cette
position qu'il aurait pu reprendre
l'audience et 6 maintenant ouais il par
exemple pour prince et six tours
processus est une possibilité
on va la regarder rapidement pour penser
si ça mène à une pression populaire il
faut bien le dire tout repenser 6 vous
obligé de reprendre en foot français 6
de toute façon ici tout est logique et
maintenant de toute façon maintenant gt5
c'est l'heure pour g4 g5 avec une
position d'attac qui promet des
perspectives intéressantes pour les
blancs puisque la la prise va être
quasiment forcé on va reprendre du
cavalier on aura nos deux cavaliers
extrêmement attentifs et ensuite on va
pouvoir menacer les pièces comme l'a
fait michael adams
mais là le problème de la personne doit
d'éviter justement qui reste avec sa
tour à 5 très mal placé dans cette
position et ça il ne veut pas donc c'est
pour ça que sur g4 il se dit je ne vais
pas reprendre tout de suite le pion
puisque ça amènera une disposition des
pièces faible je vais d'abord ramener la
tour donc ils jouent tour à 7
mais là même que la nation continue son
plan il n'ya pas de bluff
la ccc dehors surtout qu'il est dans une
position maintenant il ya plus de choix
déjà même avant g4 la situation faisait
qu'il était quasiment obligée de louer
ce coup là puisque sur tout autre coulée
noire aurait repris comme tu indiqué
eloi simplement les pions c6 avec une
position totalement totalement
convenable et une paire de fou qui
pourrait s'exprimer un jour est absurde
et 4 faible oui c'était une belle soeur
supérieure pour les noirs d'un point de
vue statique on connaît très bien ça
avec lionel puisqu'on a suivi les mêmes
stages d'entraînement et que s'ils
dorfman qui nous expliquait sa théorie
le jeu statique le jeu dynamique donc là
effectivement michael adams est en
difficulté puisque s'il laisse son
adversaire jouer cinq coups de suite il
va reprendre le dessus
un petit avantage il ne faut donc pas
lui laisser le temps de souffler il faut
y aller directement dont j'ai quatre
c'est un coup indispensable g5 aussi en
fait aucun des joueurs n'a de choix dans
cette position c'est ça qui est bien
c'est que tout est forcée enfin au
niveau du concept en tout cas je prends
chez 5 s'est efforcé quel mal est
profond
alors là ça y est ils sont là ils sont
là ils sont tous beaux donc là ça donne
des idées de sacrifice tout ça parce que
là on pourrait pas jouer un coup comme f
7 6 le câblage à nous attaquer à la fois
le cavalier 5 et le carénage 5 alors
afsset m6 voyons le s'il s'agit de cette
possibilité là puis on prend 1,6 à l'air
convaincant avec l'idée de capturer le
plan réussisse avec la dame
voilà tout à fait tout à fait
donc tu comprends aussi sceller la
manade am3 menace d'un pro 6 est en
récupère mans il faut 7 avec un gros
avantage de nombreux faux cette peur
quand on récupère le tour c'est on
récupère la trouve ces huit ça c'est sûr
avec échec probablement donc de toute
façon ici catastrophe absolue le rapper
sur noir la dame viendrait donc c'est
pas du tout c'est un coût qui vient à
l'esprit mais qui n'est pas du tout bon
aulas c'est donc c'est les possibilités
tactiques évidemment les joueurs comme
joselito adame le voit mais très vite
c'est à dire ils voient ça en demi
seconde
ils ont très vite éliminés d'office et
il passe à autre chose donc morose
évident je continue donc sur son plan
tourne à hans et 7 ça continue alors là
maintenant comment faire pour améliorer
une attaque alors on présume qu'on peut
se poser peut-être revenir à la question
justement tout à l'heure
quel est finalement la pièce qui ne
jouent pas en prison là il faut la
reformuler sais quelle pièce ne
participe à la lacc
oui comment améliorer la position des
pièces voilà la bonne question est
et si on pouvait faire un petit tour de
magie on placerait je pense les tours
sur la colline et voilà on prendra nos
deux tours et on les mettrait
directement sur la colonne j'ai donc ça
c'est l'idée effectivement donc là c'est
un autre principe qu'on connaît bien que
d'elle puisque nous avons tous les deux
travaillé avec anatolie weiser où il
faisait donc expliquer ce grand principe
aux échecs quand vous ne savez plus quoi
faire
ou quand vous trouvez que la pression
commence à piétiner il faut rechercher
la pièce qui ne joue pas et la replacer
donc michael adams l'a déjà fait avec
son 4 2 3 vous voyez c'est très simple
et maintenant il va leur faire arrêter
tout l'argent préfet j'en profite juste
pour indiquer une petite anecdote qui
relatait dans le très bon livre
confidences de l'est sur l'échiquier de
kotov ou kotov décrit une anecdote assez
amusantes ou capablanca surprend
plusieurs grands maîtres analyser une
finale ban qui peut leur poser
manifestement difficulté ça faisait à
peu près plusieurs heures qu'ils étaient
sur la position qu'ils n'arrivaient pas
trouvé le le plan gagnants et les grands
maîtres de mandat capable en cas qui est
un spécialiste reconnu bien évidement
évidemment de la seconde partie
son avis est lorsqu à fait capable en
cas à ce moment là c'est assez
impressionnant il s'est arrêté de bouger
les pièces pendant quelques secondes
il a pris deux trois pièces il les a
placé son année casse totalement
différentes et leur a dit voilà la
position atteindre est dans cette
position il aurait fait exactement la
même chose en prenant la toile ces deux
ou la tour g1 en la mettant sur la
pologne j'ai donc il faut savoir
d'effroi se poser des questions simples
pour pouvoir savoir dans quel finalement
une position placer ses pièces il y
alors ça c'est le principe pour trouver
un plan de jeu aux échecs se dire où je
voudrais que mes pièces soit puisque les
plans de jeu est question ici y en a
plus puisque c'est une position ferme et
il faut donc faire plus que des plans
pièce vous voyez lecture ne peuvent plus
trop bouger donc pour les plantes cas
c'est très sympa y est c'est vraiment la
question à se poser c'est où je veux
mettre mes pièces donc là c'est la
colonne j'ai effectivement qui est la
clé de cette de cette position alors
pour l'instant il peut pas laisser un
chrono dit pascal leroy qui gêne
casion d'où le dégagement d'où le
dégagement des gains qui permet de jouer
le coup tour g1 aux prochaines coupes
alors pas tout de suite puisqu'il ya
d'abord tour procès 6 meuros évite lui
il est à leurs fins ils alors en fait il
en retard et dr procès 6 on ne peut pas
louer tour g1 maintenant puisque la tour
c 2 threat emprise on échange donc une
paire de tours dont pensée 6 3 7 6 et
maintenant tour g1 et là on voit qu'il
ya des menaces potentielles sur le pion
que j'ai cette hormone ya une nouvelle
chose qu'on a un enfant
on avait déjà mentionné dans des gaules
mais c'était en 98 donc c'était il ya
longtemps qu'elle soit 19 de l'activité
aussi oui si mes souvenirs sont exacts
c'était dans une des provinces et les
coefficients de l'attak un contrat nike
très important le coefficient de tact on
voit le nombre de pièces à l'attack et
le nombre de pièces en défense et si
donc alors en comptant le roi un
défenseur qui vaut 3 6 en attaque on a
trois fois plus de pièces en défense
c'est à dire qu'on a un coefficient
d'attac supérieure à 3 c'est qu'il ya un
match forcément
alors ici on va comptabiliser les pièces
d'attac pour les blancs ya la dame qui
vaut 10 un cavalier 3 1 au 3ème tour
salle damas n'est pas tellement dans
l'action un premier temps la dame et
comme très proche de l'action lé preuve
du malaise de prochaines actions
donc quand on l'a 9 9 plus de cavaliers
à 6 ça fait donc 15 puis c'est le tour à
cinq sa fait 20ans défense il ya un roi
est un fou je compte pas vraiment faux
vuitton peu le comté comme un mais c'est
pas une quête de défense dans cette
position donc ça fait 6 et 1 7 faire
qu'on est pratiquement à trois fois plus
ouais donc le match se profile d'autant
plus qu'on aille très haut non les noirs
notre aide mais ne peuvent pas en faire
grand chose mais il reste qu'il faudrait
pas que les noirs jeumont coup comme g7
et six points c'est de consolider leur
ajustement laurent faible alors g7 g6
malheureusement sa personne contrôle de
toutes les cases noires autour du roi
donc on peut regarder ce coup j'essaie
jesse est une proposition alors qu'à
l'allier à 6 peut être la première
possibilité auquel on peut être amené à
penser avec l'idée de ramener la dame
éventuellement soit je crois il n'en
sait rien venir sur 4 noir comme tu a
indiqué avec la casse g7 qui qui pose
quelques petites difficultés parce que
finalement après cavaliers à 6 échecs
les noirs n'ont pas d'autre possibilité
que de prendre ce cavalier puisque soit
sera qu aucun droit et fuite on peut
imaginer que cavani h cet échec avec le
le fou 8 emprise et s'il est noir
reprennent le cavalier bref 6 puis on
prend et fils récupère tout les cas noir
avec des menaces terribles donc beaucoup
de variantes mais en fait il ya beaucoup
plus fort il ya beaucoup plus fort il ya
le coup positionnelle dans cette
position et donc cavalier
j'ai cinq ans aux 4 alors que je croyais
que vous n'aviez pas vu puisque c'est un
coup d'ordinateurs donc là on peut
relancer un peu le débat sur les
attentes chef mais ça c'est le coût
proposé à tempo par l'ordinateur quand
j'ai regardé ça tout le vent donc
cavalier vie henri iv alors salaires
positionnelle effectivement puisque on
va venir sur cette tf6 avec un cavalier
s'est donc mis au monde ici que les
normes pas prendre cavaliers à cause de
damages 6 qui menace matin j'ai cet
imparable équipe de la semaine tanger
s'est totalement imparable donc on ne
peut pas prendre ce cavalier ou 4 le
cavalier h5 lui est bien défendu donc à
venir
un cavalier sur la case clé celui de la
dame est lassé de tout des machines qui
m'ont assez embrouillée dame à chis
également voyez plutôt d'acheter ce
drame artistique et menaçant donc des
machines ici est tout simplement
imparables par des moyens normaux donc
sous une fuite
oui mais l'info il fit sa s'expose à un
matt prenons extrêmement rapide à base
de cavaliers h ont ainsi suivi damage
toi je ne pense pas qu'on puisse espérer
tenir cette position là en tout cas il
ya trop de cases blanches ces fameux
coefficient d'attac seimat de manière
forcée donc regardons peut-être une
autre possibilité de défense dans cette
position là après avoir compté on sait
ni donc là par principe que c'était ma
force et c'est confirmé informatiquement
parlant
ouais donc l'ordinateur de jeu toujours
un très bon rôle en tant que
vérificateur d'orthographe
comme nicolas giffard c'est confirmé ici
il n'y a plus de défenses il ya trop de
casse à l'attaqué donc une fois de plus
les principes sont confirmés par
l'analyse
numérique en voyant passer quelques
ajouts mermoz et beach préfère voir le
ventre plein oui donc ramasse le pion b2
et là c'est l'heure de cavani projet 7
de toute façon tout marché enfin je
rigole un peu mais il y avait tellement
pièce blanche qui était sur la place
donc le premier cas la largesse après
fils angers7
mais alors si le roi prend le canal
orange et 7 il ya match très très vite
alors voyons rien à voir entre 100 et
300 cavaliers donc ça c'est une superbe
coup du sort qu'amélie prendre d'essai
c'est un coup dit on sait attendu ses
attendus non on va pas on veut pas non
plus enflammé le enflammé l'échiquier
c'est un coût attendu toutes les pièces
blanches sont là bon si on voit bien la
position si on regarde la position dans
cette position là d'un prend b2 qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire à part qu'elle est
proche et 7 on peut faire un coup
on n'a pas le choix tout simplement donc
cette insulte à beaucoup mais il est
forcé il est forcé parce que sinon
justement les noirs vont commencer à
revenir avec leur pièce ils ont tour
c'est sérieux c'est 3 caraïbes dams et
de qu'arrive peut-être pour faire des
échecs sur les cases blanches
en tout cas ça commence à bouger côtés
de marc maroselli qui n'est pas non plus
complètement à la rue dans cette
position donc c'est l'ordre qui les
prend g7 il faut le faire c'est précis
c'est le bon moment et c'est très fort
et projet 7
alors donc voyons les divans ces deux là
ont trois projets cette empreinte g7
cavalli prend 1,6 doble tchèque donc
double échec est l'échec du cavalier et
échec de la tour échec du cavalier ici
et de la tour comme ça donc le roi doit
bouger quand ces doubles échecs long
courriers interposés puisqu'on échec de
deux endroits différents dont il n'y a
pas d'autre solution que de bouger droit
on va par exemple soit 1 15 h 7
il ad'ailleurs 3 damas trois échecs donc
là le fameux maths je ne sais pas quoi
vivre un nom et un effet d'annoncé il
est tellement connu ce matin
enfin ce n'est pas mal puisque ayant
meublé colonnes une interposition voilà
c'est tout sur colonne d'un profond
échec et mat
et voilà donc ça c'est une possibilité
de rapprocher cette se heurte à un match
fort s'est très vite
ouais donc morose et vici s'ils ne
trouvent pas de solution tout simplement
parce qu il
on n'a pas il joue donc dame c3 et
michael adams soit très tranquille très
heureux à l'anglais alan gleizes kabylie
profonde et une pièce de plus une pièce
de plus net donc il ya des possibilités
de jeu d'un pour retrouver ce que j'ai
toujours passé mais de toute façon cet
archipel dans une pièce de plus à ce
niveau là ça ne pardonne pas donc
donc c'est une partie vraiment linéaire
dans macadam superbe alors résumons la
partie michael adams surprend morozevich
par une nouveauté ont par ailleurs
dernières parties ouais qu'il arrive à
conserver sanctions c'est le fou g5 la
doctrine du fmi
il arrive à conserver son pion
suffisamment longtemps c'est à dire
qu'il fait une diversion max option le
temps que morose et vif se regroupent
pour aller ramasser le pion qui met du
puisque c'est un pion qui va être perdu
le temps qu'ils se regroupent pour à
l'époque selon michael adams a déjà
transféré toutes ces pièces étaient la
défense d'options de l'autre côté à
l'attack du roi amoureuse et beach et là
ça se conclut par une pointe final donc
avec projet set quand il y avait toutes
les pièces à l'attack quelques on le
sait qu'elles ont gagné une pièce et
dans la pression finale très logiquement
morozevich abandonne c'est une très très
bonne partie un élevage je pense que
c'est une partie très instructive et qui
est très caractéristique un petit peu du
style aussi de michael adams avec plein
de petits pièges posés régulièrement
notamment le clan c5 qui est jamais
finalement prenables dans le début d'un
début de partie et c'est vrai adams en
tout cas c'est comme ça tu le ressens
pose énormément de petits pièges comme
ça le petit piège tactique dans ces
parties quand quand on regarde on a
l'impression que la pétition est stable
que les noirs vont pouvoir récupérer le
pion c5 mais non adams a toujours des
tas de petites astuces faut dire que
c'est un joueur qui est très concentré
par rapport aux autres joueurs
lorsqu'on observe adams on s'aperçoit
qu'il restait 6 pendant toute sa partie
c'est très très impressionnant et là où
les adversaires se promène sur le temps
de réflexion de leurs adversaires
justement adam subi reste concentré
toute toute la partie et cr c'est un
signe que c'est installera champions un
homme s'est effectivement extrêmement
concentré dans beaucoup puisque
la voix dormir plus de 10 heures par
nuit entre 10 et 12 ans qui est quand
même beaucoup
il n'a pas la réputation d'un gros
bosseur c'est pas un c'est pas un homme
qui travaille les échecs mais en tout
cas il un très bon feeling il comprend
bien les positions effectivement et
chaussées système qui connaît très bien
et là il a il a su en profiter donc
michael adams toute façon à sarajevo a
fait huit points sur 11
ce cas une performance à plus de 2800
points elo probablement donc
exceptionnel michael adams de toute
façon très en forme en ce moment et qui
gagne un prix de bordeaux qui rappelons
le a gagné le grand prix de bordeaux
fait donc on va on va passer à notre
deuxième en briques avec les actes
l'actualité de la semaine
oui tout à fait voilà donc voilà donc
c'est bon on est revenus donc actualité
de la semaine avec donc lausanne le
lausanne d'oeil aux master's donc avec
la présence de laurent frayssinet et
donc de alexander de les choux que
vladimir malakhov alexander galt
hindustan ponomariov bouxom suit on va y
arriver
florian génie et d'anis dropped laulan
n'est donc en fait et tout s'est joué en
une caractéristique elle sait qu'elles
sont très très jeune et très très fort
voilà donc en principe à lausanne
apparemment est en train de se jouer la
relève pour le grand gars y ont
peut-être son successeur est déjà plus
vieux mais en tout cas on ne sait pas ce
qu'on voit pas qui dans la génération
actuelle peut battre kasparov
par contre on est peinards l'écho ils
ont l'air très prometteur wipitta les
causes éventuelles moment où j'ai vite
eu peut-être avec un extérieur voit
beaucoup
n'y crois pas n'y croient pas
malheureusement on pense quand même que
ça sera la génération suivante qui
viendra à bout de ce rouleau compresseur
des années 80 que garry kasparov fidèles
fourni tellement d'énergie pour battre
car pauvreté d'accueil avance énorme
énergie énorme c'est au delà de au delà
du convenable il est vraiment largement
au dessus donc on présuppose que ce
tournoi est annonciateur en tout cas de
future génération et il y à un joueur
très très fort donc en tête ponomariov
qui je pense a dû se qualifier avant la
bassée premier tour et un moment gagné
le deuxième vient passer un premier
temps des pronoms gagné deuxième aussi
alors à noter la présence de notre star
française
il a en deuxième tour il mener à une
mise au point d'un contre-meeting où il
venait d'un point il était déjà bien au
moment où on a regardé dans la deuxième
partie avec les noirs donc pas un
problème pour ponomariov des parents va
se qualifier galkin drapeau le champion
du monde junior donc c'est un bon joueur
aussi mais il ya surtout le rend facile
et laurent fascine aimerait donc contre
un constat hexagonal vice champion du
monde juniors mais malheureusement qui a
chuté au premier coup au premier qu'au
premier tour par an contre alexander du
siècle et il a lourdement chuté
lourdement chuté effectivement la
première partie il avait les noirs et
s'est fait en fumée dans une d'âge d'or
quand je dis en fumée c'est à dire qu'il
a mal géré l'ouverture et qu'ensuite il
ya une option passé en c6 qui l'a
torturé jusqu'au bout donc il a perdu la
première partie dans la deuxième il a
sorti son arme secrète
c'est à dire la variante des changes de
l'espagnol qui connaît très très bien il
a failli battre michael adams avec ça
mais dont il a obtenu une passion qui
était pleine de plein de bonnes
perspectives
mais n'a pas réussi à conclure et donc
match du blond qui comme rappelons quand
même que le système du temps c'est des
matches à élimination directe le 20 juin
contre lui tu laurent frayssinet taxis
des vélos à jouer contre le troisième
qui est donc le russe great jouques
première partie donc c'était des
mini-matchs en deux parties il est venu
il faut gagner lille gagne pas il fait
nul dont qui les élimine
tout simplement enfin en suisse on n'est
pas éliminé bon il continue à jouer
puisqu'il se mange les matchs de
placement pour le match de classement
pour madonna dont il faut rappeler la
formule sa femme une formule à
élimination directe justement souvent
leur dire c'est que y'a pas
d'élimination mais c'est une formule
systems group c'est à dire que dès qu'on
a perdu un match on ne peut plus gagner
le tournoi à la différence des tons veut
fermer ou si on perd la première ronde
ce n'est pas grave puisqu'on peut encore
revenir ici c'est l'élimination dans ce
sens-là l'élimination de direct donc
peut-être des pronostics quand même beau
cheval revient ponomariov ponomariov
faire très fort ici
d'accord on pourra noter quand même la
présence de boules samedi qui a 13 ans
et qui est je crois le plus jeune grand
maître de l'histoire du jeu d'échecs
chinois donc la ville démontre la
vitalité des échecs en chinois oui alors
c'est vrai que maintenant les
échappements chine se développe à toute
vitesse il ya notre ex champion du monde
anatoli karpov qui fait une grosse
prestation là bas qui est un peu
l'ambassadeur du jeu d'échecs en chine
on peut dire ça comme ça et ça se
développe il ya déjà du champion du
monde jeunes championnes du monde
chinoises wang keyun et des des grands
matches chinois dimanche quand il ya
franchement un peu plus des nombreux un
peu tous ces noms mais il y en a
beaucoup le niveau de gens en chine est
très très fort et il ya donc maintenant
la star junior n'avoir même
plus le mondial la star fût king la star
pepy chinoise donc boubsi qui est très
très fort je crois qu'il ya battu
radjabov en match enfin en tout cas là
on est dans la nouvelle génération
on peut pas trop céder jours qu'on
connaît pas très bien c'est un peu comme
des nouveaux boxeurs qui arrivent ils
ont tous leur style dans le sens de ce
prêtre on les connaît pas encore très
bien avant tout cas ici il ya donc à
lausanne il ya un très très bel
échantillonnage des jeunes mondiaux il
ya quand même un phénomène qui est l'âge
de l'obtention du titre de grand maître
qui ne cesse de descendre
actuellement les jeunes ont de leur
disposition des outils des outils assez
impressionnant pour se préparer que
leurs prédécesseurs prédécesseur n'avait
pas effectivement niveau moyen augmente
on va rester on va rester justement dans
l'informatique
parce que
on annonce donc tourner à dortmund dont
on avait fait un très bon reportage
l'année dernière donc vous invite à voir
d'aller différer la différence des
grenades sur l'autoroute octobre c'était
au mois de juillet de l'année dernière
il faut remonter assez loin dans les
archives mais on peut le retrouver on
peut y arriver
ou alors avec le moteur de recherche
doivent être le moteur de recherche
aussi d'un canal web
pas facile à trouver ce moteur de
recherche encore mais c'est possible
aussi donc retrouver ce reportage sur le
tour à tour nicky est très très fort
avec cette année la présence de bas
relief michael adams your own piquette
on a beaucoup parlé de piquette qu'elle
fait d'excellents résultats il a gagné
notamment de caspar enfin inauguré
inaugurera le grand prix sur internet
battant kasparov au final en battant
castres olympique est en pleine forme
vladimir kramnik qui lui aussi est en
pleine forme et qui qui se prépare pour
son match contre kasparov qui devrait
avoir lieu fin novembre
donc c'est pour ça qu'il n'a pas voulu
sarajevo probablement parce qu'il
voulait pas rencontrer les comptes de
joueurs se préparent pour le match et
c'est de s'éviter dans le tournoi oui
aux essais de s'éviter devant fait donc
cramique de chouettes en compte
principalement parce qu'il aime beaucoup
la ville et il s'entend très bien avec
les organisateurs donc chronique à
dortmund c'est une tradition ça fait
cinq ans qu'il faut le tournoi ici sans
vraiment gagner trois fois de suite on
est bien trop forte suite la lumière
kramnik l'admira confiant il est une
autre vice champion du monde officiel il
faut pas oublier la nuit un conte bien
que tu es en finale du championnat du
monde contre kalichman et d'ailleurs
khalid mhadjou et émettant des râles
hickman jouer et à nantes joue ainsi que
peter l'écho on va retrouver notre petit
peter l'écho ainsi que robert hue
minerve alors peter les coupes qui n'a
pas joué depuis depuis linares n'a pas
joué depuis une adresse donc il avait
envie de prendre du repos c'est ce qu'il
est en train de faire on l'a vu
review donc là que vous pouvez revoir
sur l'émission linares et hervé qu'on
voulait se reposer donc il s'est reposé
et là espérons qu'il reviendra en forme
à dortmund en tout cas c'est le seul
tenant du titre assez vite été remporté
le tournoi qu'il avait remporté cette
année donc et dans vos joueurs et voilà
donc quand je revenais à un nouveau
joueur tout à fait spécial pourtant
lionel puisque ces juniors 6
l'ordinateur qui va jouer le tour alors
c'est pour ma part pas un nouveau jeune
joueur je le connais depuis pas mal
d'années en fait c'est un logiciel qui a
pas mal évolué depuis les anciennes
versions
et c'est vrai que ce qui caractérise
junior par rapport aux autres logiciels
c'est son style qui est très stratégique
en fait aujourd'hui on est arrivé à un
stade où tous les logiciels on sait on a
atteint une capacité une force de jeu
qui est intouchable sauf pour les
vraiment les tous meilleurs joueurs du
monde et ce qui différencie un logiciel
par rapport à un autre c'est son style
et c'est vrai que junior sera plutôt
stratégique alors d'autres programmes
notamment en afrique ce sera plus fort
tactiquement
donc ça c'est un des critères
aujourd'hui donc on arrive à
personnaliser les vaches à lait le style
de la machine dépend à l'origine du
style du programmeur qui peut imposer de
par l'évaluation qui et les critères
d'évaluation qui va donner aux logiciels
une tendance et c'est vrai qu'au fritz
est très très fort tactiquement et
laurent lui sera plus fort ce que
j'ignore a déjà fait des tournois comme
ça contre des hommes
oui junior a fait des pas mal de
performance je crois de mémoire qui
l'avait battu geel fendent il ya
quelques mois de cela il avait battu
aussi si je dis pas de bêtises judit
polgar je crois que les scalps de gros
de grands maîtres pour des programmes
comme junior aujourd'hui sont plus que
démontrer et
et c'est vrai qu'à mon avis c'est un
logiciel qui risque de faire pas mal
parlé lui dans la mesure où il existe
une version outils processeur de ce
programme qui permet donc théoriquement
au logiciel de d'accéder à une vitesse
de calcul beaucoup plus grande que les
autres logiciels qui n'ont pas encore de
version multi processeurs à dortmund il
sera probablement multiprocesseurs
évidemment puisque pour maximiser sa
performance les la compagnie qui produit
junior 6 n'a pas lésiné sur les moyens
on verra ça on verra ça en tout cas ça
risque d'être très intéressant de voir
un programme en confrontée comme ça non
à l'élite mondiale parce que là on a
vraiment l'élite mondiale en attendait
la cram michela peter l'écho et la adams
est là donc ça fait 4 4 des quatre des
sept meilleurs joueurs du monde qui sont
là donc ça va ça devrait être très
intéressant à suivre une confrontation
pour voir si les meilleurs joueurs du
monde devrait facilement disposé de
l'alimentaire ont peint oui alors oui
effectivement ça va être ça va être très
très sympa dans ce parce que
effectivement je peux le championnat de
hollande par équipes c'est sympa mais là
les joueurs sont quand même d'un autre
niveau sont vraiment heureuse c'est par
gilles font partie de l'élite mondiale
et on va voir comment notre ami juniors
donc joueurs positionnelle va se
comporter face à ces joueurs de très
haut niveau
alors si on peut se lancer dans un petit
jeu de pronostics pour ma part j'ai je
pense que junior devrait finir vraiment
dans les tout premiers rôles et dans les
trois premiers c'est mon petit mon petit
pronostic pronostics du mana les trois
premiers mots qui n'engage que lui en
amérique se traite à fait ça risque
d'être dur quand même parce que
peut-être compréhension positionnelle de
ces joueurs là va au delà de 6 on voit
la colombe fritz a perdu contre
contrebande bilie bi oui il reste encore
des progrès à faire je pense
qu'actuellement effectivement logiciel
est pas tout à fait
dans les dents les vraiment les cinq
meilleurs joueurs du monde mais avec la
puissance de calcul la cadence je pense
que je n'y aura toutes ses chances est
bon les pronostics comme disait loi dans
quelques mois donc
autre actualité le tournoi de valence
web wem à mieux ensuite qui s'est
terminée avec la victoire de judit
polgar très bien pris une victoire avec
quatre points sur six avec 4 joueurs en
tout oui donc les premières sur quatre -
première sur quatre en tout à fait et
c'est pas mal puisque judit polgar
enlève ainsi un nouveau tournoi elle
avait déjà gagné le jabra classique en
indonésie c'est donc sa deuxième
victoire consécutive dans un tournoi qui
réunissait donc henderson team année
taille dès lors il a personne donc c'est
pas mal alors la qualité des parties est
très correct et la voiture anderson et
imane dans les trois premières rondes et
ensuite elle a fini en roue libre avec
trois nuls s'assurant la première place
tout seul est détaché alors entre un
fonds est intéressante aussi c'est le
terrain de francfort qui disent qu'ils
amassent et pour lequel on va faire un
spécial diagonale avec un reportage sur
place
oh oui alors déjà il y en aura un bord
de route enfin non plutôt le contraire
il y en aura un pour francfort mais on
en retient pour dortmund et à francfort
c'est superbe
puisque le plateau et il n'y a pas mieux
planifier les six joueurs
les six meilleurs joueurs de la planète
les six meilleurs joueurs du monde
seront là donc un kasparov crâne nicanor
shirov bronze effectivement évité déco
et peter les cowboys a fait un plateau
noren voyez alors oui et non ça va être
ça va être vraiment un super tu auras
donc diagonale sera là bas on va
attraper autant d'interviews que ce sera
possible
on espère tous les avoirs en tout cas
pour un reportage choc non portage sont
donc ça a lieu les nattes alors de tête
c'est délicat mais ça a lieu
dc dc manny sid deux ou trois semaines
je pense que c'est la troisième semaine
du mois de juin voilà donc très bientôt
donc un reportage spécial des voyages
sur ce super tombant de francfort dont
qui s'annonce comme le choc à ne pas
rentrer à ne pas manquer pardon de ne
pas rentrer erreur linguistique voilà
donc des mercis lionel d'être passés
nous voir
merci à vous de m'avoir invité donc
allemands se rendant en émoi la semaine
prochaine à priori oui voilà la semaine
prochaine enfin
oui